well therefore k met this week it's a
good video game do we agree gentlemen I
think it's a great video gear depends on
which platform you're playing on oh
really yeah oh right yeah what are you
even playing on I so are if you just
went up reviews i guess i should say
okay and i played through it on ps4
because that's what they sent first
wounds the console versions of the game
and then pc followed up i wish they had
done it the other way around because the
pc version that game is significantly
better so you did two reviews well so
the text is identical because you know
we always figure that you know people
that are playing one version would want
to know about the other versions so
rather than just tailor the text
differently but yes so the pc got four
stars and the the console version got
three so to speak about i guess about
the technical issues you came on the
console version or the ps4 bro i mean
the the framerate is a train wreck in
that game you know dead depending on
where you are it just you know indoor
areas seem to perform worse than outdoor
areas you know it started near the
beginning of the game nossing like every
time you reload the gun is just like why
is so chunky and then just progressively
as you keep playing like wait this
doesn't look right this doesn't look
right then you know a lot of the
framerate stuff specifically culminated
in a late game moment for me you're kind
of you're in a large area i'm going to
try to talk vaguely yeah you're in kind
of a large area but it's catwalks so
it's kind of a tight moving movement
space maybe about a dozen enemies it was
kind of hard to count them at some point
because there were more enemies on the
screen than frames per second you know
it was like baby five frames per second
or something you know and it's like I'm
trying to like at some point you can't
aim the gun when it's that bad that's
doesn't freeze time so right that's not
like a great option either to shoot your
way through that thing so it just became
like well I need to heal every 15
seconds to keep my health up and try to
use all of my stealth boys to get out of
it Wow back to where the framerate lives
it's crazy because we had it in office
obviously as well in the past week or so
I played maybe like 15 hours on xbox one
family wasn't you know it was like I
paint on PC subsequently and it was like
a difference yeah and but it never
really got like super bad honest I was
in sometimes like the God raised in the
forest
day but it never crunched bad like that
did you experience that much when you're
playing did the only moment that I
experienced that is as bad as you're
describing was within a building where
they were trying to do some sort of like
particles smoke effect thing and it was
the first time I had seen it and seen
frame rate that bad but I never had any
sort of like moment where the glitches
like or frame rate rather impacted the
my abilities in combat right on I mean
I've heard a lot of people say similar
things I'm surprised to hear it's that
bad for you yeah and it's you know and
the xbox one version you know has that
kind of you know that those digital
foundries piece was kind of like talking
about just straight-up stopping and then
the recommendation there seems to be
play the game off an external hard drive
which I risk point actually play because
USB 3 s faster than whatever they have
said an eternal in the SATA so I've
actually I moved to an external hard
drive on Xbox one a while ago so I'm
playing that version I didn't see
anything quite as bad as what people had
talked about but it certainly was you
know right around ps4 levels of
performance for me so yeah those
versions of the game just have an extra
layer I mean these games are always
messed up right I mean Bethesda ships
buggy weird games but in this case like
the console versions were just an extra
level of messed up yours like an either
this isn't well it's a bizarre can't
recommend this anymore it's a bizarre
echo of the PlayStation 3 version yeah
we're gonna yeah things like they sneak
a Cell processor and to the pip-boy that
comes with it or something like yeah
messed up so uh so i guess like let's
talk about glitches in terms of when new
games come here because obviously like
there have been some absolute horror
shows over the past couple years we've
had our anniversary this time last year
like batman arkham knight is just
command and pc apparently it's still
jacked up a little bit yeah 3 our people
nowadays kind of more sensitive to
glitches because of those types of
stories or is this the same as it's ever
been I think games are shipping in
lesser states you know like like games
you know as games get more and more
complicated than don't have an infinite
amount of dollars and time to throw at
QA and then you know and fix all these
things prior to ship and you know it's
hard to say I every games going to have
a different story attached to
whether it's like well they must manage
the time and just didn't have time to
you know really get a final polish pass
on it or or whatever it's hard to know
and it's hard to care because at the end
of the day like people buy a game they
expect it to work and these days that's
just seemed less and less certain you
know I just came off of yeah I mean
obviously like the pc version of batman
is super crazy yeah you know they took
it off sale for a while and brought it
back out and i are still people having
problems with it that you know it at
least they're offering refunds through
the end of the year with that one you
know instead of like a yeah what hey
maybe if you had 12 gigs of ram i can
wait doesn't this run on consoles that
dont have it anyway but it's crazy that
there are games like that which have so
many people having problems with them
like anecdotally one of my best mates
back home in Ireland but what that game
didn't read any news about worked
perfectly fine completed it before it
was taken down right is it just gotten
so difficult to like QA this stuff
because i don't know like well he was
saying so different their games are
becoming so much more complicated and
the tech behind them is so much more
complicated that these intricacies
create moments so many moments where
things can just go wrong and go haywire
and that's the thing that you know is
specifically talking about fallout like
I mean sometimes it works right all
right yeah you know fallout allows you
to do so many different things and pick
up so many different there's so many
different places where fallout can break
yeah more so than most other games so it
may be it's not surprising sorry that
it's so busted but that doesn't make it
forgivable but yeah I like its
replacement sometimes it's awesome but
in the fallout case like those games
been broken the exact same way since
oblivion if not before and at some point
it's like well you know yeah it's roll
the dice like I've been on the other end
of the conversation we're having right
now where I finish new vegas and said
this game's fine yeah and then people
are like you're crazy um so that's just
how it goes sometimes so what is that
like a deeply personal thing or is it an
expectation thing because like going
into playing fallout I'm like okay last
night i was playing just three super
mutants all there and i blow to them up
and then the third one is there still
stirring the pot
as if nothing happened what's her I'm
like his father whereas if that was like
a you know well half life 3 I might go
hey that's [ __ ] yeah I think that
you know people maybe gotten conditioned
to expect these games to be messed up
and and maybe that's certainly part of
it but I don't know for me I think the
expectations were not met because I
looked at it like well you know they've
been making these games for a very long
time they've had these issues all along
but now they're moving on to a new
generation of technology their baseline
their low spec for consoles will be up a
rung yeah and on x86 hardware you know
so you looking like well maybe there are
now fewer variables and they could
actually tighten some of this stuff up
but then I sent my dog companion away
and never saw it again you know but then
I spent an hour trying to click on a
quest objective and having it not
activate and having to fast travel away
and back and read launch the game
multiple times before it would actually
do anything and you know that's all
stuff that you know those are all
stories that could just as easily apply
to new vegas fallout 3 Skyrim oblivion
but you know for me it's one of those
things where it's like we want to expect
more out of our games you know
technology improves and you'd think that
they would have gotten better at this
stuff but apparently they spent their
time somewhere else and that's maybe the
larger problem is i look at fallout 4
and i don't know where they spent that
time right because it's not like it's
that's different yeah you know the
workshop stuff the the base building
stuffs in there for whatever reason and
it seems like a natural evolution of
their in-house development that they
figured hey we can just add this to the
game why not Yeah right we'd like
something new to show at e3 let's just
show this just do this like you know
people that modded the game liked
building bases at some point so maybe
they won't wanted to just do that but is
one of the things where it's like you
look at it and go like this is roughly
the same as previous games that the
studio has made it doesn't necessarily
seem larger in scope or smaller it's
just kind of that thing so for it to
ship out again and be more or less just
as glitchy and messed up as their
previous games i think is super crazy
and stepping away from fallout 4
specifically it this is sort of getting
into the realm of conspiracy theory but
you know with the
advantages of people having high
bandwidth internet connections and the
pervasiveness of day one patches now
like our developers and publishers
shipping games with packed with bugs and
short fallings knowing that they can
scrap them or patch them up later on oh
I totally think so a lot of game
development is driven by milestones
where a publisher says we need you to
hit X feature on X date otherwise you
will lose budget and they'll be other
ramifications so when you have strict
milestones like that and then it comes
closer and closer to shipping you really
need to start you know hitting those
from what I understand to to make the
whole thing worthwhile and yes there is
the nature of updates and DLCs now that
we've all kind of grown accustomed to
and have thus made it capable for
publishers and developers to make
excuses and stuff it's not great but I
think that that is perhaps why I'm sure
you know it's it's a handful of things
you know the disks have to be pressed X
number of days before they're on the
streets so they have to be you know
they're not done on street donde one
they're done a month before that and
then it's like okay now we need this
extra time to work on whatever this day
one patch is going to be or you know
start working on DLC or whatever it ends
up being you know back before you could
just patch a console game you'd run into
things that you know i remember it was
one of the tomb raider games on ps2 i
believe where they shipped it broken and
it was just something that was like well
this is a bad glitch and the console
manufacturer waived it and said you can
ship you know it was they called it a
running Rev they're like okay look you
can put out this many copies of this
game and then you'll fix this thing and
reshipping so they were basically
willing to allow a certain number of
copies with you know and it wasn't like
something that every single user was
going to find right people there's
something along the lines if they forgot
to put in a weapon but they put the
ammunition in maybe it was like the [ __ ]
one of the shotguns wasn't I never ended
up hearing the back end of it of like
what the problem actually was it was
more just like someone in PR going like
yeah by the way this copy we're shipping
is going to be kind of rare why because
we're working on exclusive j1 edition
right day one edition more broken um so
you know this sort of stuff used to
happen then too you know Nintendo won't
look muy made people should send
cartridges back to them I placed and
stuff like that there there are
definitely multiple versions of games
like Star Fox and
mario all-stars and stuff like that that
just kind of quietly were revved in the
background so you know that's been going
on a long time it's just now we have the
power to fix these things and I think a
lot of people complain about day one
patches but it's the way of things the
alternative of like setting all this
stuff in stone isn't going to instantly
fix all these problems and make them
glitch free as much as we'd like to
believe that like that would force them
to get it right the first time it
wouldn't it wouldn't you know it made my
claim some things but like these things
are there too many moving parts and
there are too many marketing oriented
you know they have together ship day you
know they're not that many big games
coming out anymore but they announce
their dates so far in advance that like
there's so much money being spent on
marketing campaigns and television and
sponsorships and all this other stuff
all these you know twitch streamers that
have to get their game in so they can
start streaming a lot and these are the
things that give people the budgets to
make the games that we're talking about
to yeah like that's the sort of stuff
that if we want the games that we love
like fallout that are these big
expansive games to continue we kind of
have to buy into that system otherwise
where's the money going to come from
yeah it's it's a tricky problem there
are ton of moving parts on all ends that
thing that are just kind of systemic to
the way that big games get developed a
produced marketed and shipped and it
sounds like it's if why you guys are
saying is correct it sounds like this is
something that we're not going to see
less of we could possibly see more of it
well you know nothing's been quite as
broken as a Shasta screed unity yeah
yeah has it you know like man you could
say well okay yeah bad but that's only
one version of it so that better or
worse I don't even know me I'd like to
think that we've kind of crossed a
threshold where the leaps in technology
and scope of games is starting to like
level out a little bit and so maybe
these sort of huge ambitious projects
will seem relatively normal in light of
regular development and so hope you
don't people learn their lessons fallout
4 is a good example of how that didn't
happen yeah but no one's gonna learn I
mean the lesson learned from fallout 4
is gonna be hey look at us we just sold
another 20 million copies of a game
you're broken just as broken as the last
one which also sold 20 million copies
and you know likes no one's gonna learn
anything but could they do it again
could they still yeah I guess that's the
question is like who could the next
bethesda game studios game be
this messed up yeah I'd like to think no
yeah i would i would definitely like to
think now but i guess I'll find out get
another seven year five years yeah now
my new vegas is that like wat 18 months
after three so first year city to Skyrim
to right yes skyla elder scrolls online
is gonna kill your guy written for a new
like single-player Elder Scrolls game
your time soon they're probably way too
behind that so Jeff cross your fingers
and do works properly do plays well what
from what I played it plays wonderfully
I've played the multiplayer stuff it's a
different engine though to osu that's
just that's the EdTech engine is broken
in an entirely different way Oh every
game is a John Goodman [ __ ] REI link at
that point oh really yeah you just get
John Goodman automatically in Conway's
jeff gerstmann Peter Brian's like you so
much for coming on telling us how broken
video games are let us know how broken
you think video games are and the
comment box below
you